i think the media don't really
understand my decision to go to
university which three major characters
nearly quit the harry potter franchise
being thrown into success and fame at
such a young age was tough for many of
the harry potter actors and sometimes
they buckled under the pressure you
would feel watched when you went into a
bar actors were accused of doing
everything from drugs to underage
drinking and having inappropriate
relationships
these actors got a whole lot of
attention they weren't looking for i'm
sad to not be a part of this anymore
being part of one of the most successful
franchises in the world is an absolute
dream for an actor but for some their
priorities are a bit different
while she was making loads of money and
part of a very special project watson's
heart was pulling her towards education
the actress also wasn't a fan of how
intense the filming schedule was
after doing the goblet of fire she felt
totally out of control as all of her
time was being controlled and dictated
by other people leaving her feeling
totally trapped
it just was overwhelming
in the end the actress stuck around and
the producers worked to accommodate her
schedule and watson wound up going to
both brown and oxford university
hermione welcome back it was a dream
situation watson got to fulfill her
academic desires and we got to see her
play hermione for all of the films
when harry potter himself watches the
movies great memories aren't always what
comes flooding back daniel radcliffe is
actually able to identify when he was
drunk when filming the pressure grew as
the actor rose to intense fame and to
cope radcliffe turned to alcohol and the
situation started to get out of control
quite quickly while the actor never
drank while he was on set he would often
consume enough the night before that
he'd show up to set and perform while he
was still inebriated or in his own words
dead behind the eyes
they get scary when they get older you
spoiled everything
when daniel radcliffe got intimate for
the first time he was just 16 and got
together with a much older woman the
significant age gap was awkward but the
woman was a friend of radcliffs and
someone he knew quite well making the
whole situation a bit more
understandable i wasn't into it emma
watson wasn't the only one who
considered quitting the franchise
the boy who lived actually almost left
his role after filming the prisoner of
azkaban he was enjoying his time but
after rising to success so quickly
playing such an iconic role radcliffe
worried he may be typecast and thought
it would be smart to pursue other types
of roles to ensure he wouldn't forever
be known as just harry potter however
the role was pretty once in a lifetime
and at his age it was hard to get better
jobs than pursuing adventure at hogwarts
what part of this isn't living up to
your expectations the final member of
the golden trio rupert grint was ready
to quit the franchise a few times over
the course of filming while it was a
dream job the actor became overwhelmed
with how much it took over his life
completely and really struggled with the
rapid rise to extreme fame what's this
tonic for the nerves the rule carried a
lot of pressure as well since there was
such a hype to live up to with the
series being so popular
it's pretty tough trying to picture
anyone else playing ron
the old conjurer can see at the back of
his head
sheamus finnegan actor devin murray
wound up getting into trouble with his
agent who accused him of not sharing his
earnings as he'd been meant to after
goblet of fire the actor didn't pay the
agent neil brooks well over two hundred
thousand pounds
so murray was ordered to pay up a
whopping 210 000 pounds to brooks
i'll do this
actually i can
before the whole franchise even started
there was some drama between cast
members
emma thompson aka professor trelawny had
to work with the woman who broke up her
marriage with kenneth branagh aka
professor gilderoy lockhart
thompson and brana had been married for
six years before the trilani actress
called it off after discovering her
husband had had an affair with none
other than helena bonham carter or in
the harry potter universe bellatrix
lestrange danger
bonham carter and brana actually wound
up being together for five years after
the fact but eventually that
relationship dissolved as well
while it may seem like the situation
would have been very awkward thompson
opened up explaining that it was in the
past and the actresses were okay with
each other despite how rough a start
they had
and request that he keep his abnormally
large snows out of other people's
business
radcliffe had major fans which meant he
also had a number of options when it
came to women many fans were excited by
the chance to be with the harry potter
and when given the option radcliffe
didn't always turn down fans and instead
would indulge in one night stands every
now and then when he'd been drinking
hey she's only interested in you because
she thinks you're the chosen one no
doubt being under the pressure of
performing in such a major franchise is
a struggle
crush it don't cut it rupert grint and
daniel radcliffe made headlines when the
two of them were accused of being caught
consuming cannabis
[Music]
it was reported that daniel had consumed
some of the illegal substance at a party
while someone who looked a lot like
grint was caught in a photo
both actors and their reps denied the
allegations in the end though it's a
disappointment for for him and and the
franchise in 2009 london no one wanted
to be caught with cannabis on them
especially not an actor
unfortunately for hogwarts bully crab
actor jamie waylett he was both carrying
and growing enough to get into a lot of
trouble
there were eight bags of the illegal
substance in his car which was only made
worse by the approximately two thousand
pounds worth of plants he was growing at
home
waylett had to pay for his crime with
over 100 hours of community service
after pleading guilty i've just accepted
it now emma watson was unfortunately
caught in some uncomfortable situations
when it came to her red carpet
appearances paparazzi can be ruthless
and they embarrassed watson when they
caught a snap of the actress getting out
of a car and exposing her underwear to
the public in the process another time
the wind turned against her and blew her
dress up in a way that exposed her
underwear yet again when she was working
the red carpet before seeing the half
blood prince
it was me
i swear i didn't mean to the youngest
weasley found herself in an awkward
situation when a photograph surfaced of
her allegedly rolling a joint the photo
came out just after wrapping the half
blood prince when wright was just 17
years old this was definitely a
scandalous photo to have floating around
and the truth of what was happening in
the photo has never actually been
confirmed they get dressed now may not
be pleasant
a gringotts goblin from the very first
harry potter film found himself in quite
a bit of trouble when he was accused of
indecent exposure on a train the actor
ended up needing to do a sex offenders
course after he was charged as guilty in
court and had to pay a 500 pound fine
they say a picture is worth a thousand
words and in emma watson's case the
story being told was quite the scandal
the actress was just 15 when a picture
of her with a bottle of corona held to
her mouth was circulated online while it
looked very bad the actress had just
been posing and used the bottle as a
prop since she only began drinking when
she was of legal age in the u.s since
she was attending brown university there
daniel radcliffe wasn't shy when it came
to sharing how he felt about the oscars
calling them out for not recognizing
commercial films fairly but we're hoping
that they kind of do considering how
brilliant the harry potter movies were
radcliffe felt the films were more
deserving of nominations than other
movies and even named hugo as an example
of one that wasn't up to par
while he definitely made some fair
points we're not too sure the academy
was much of a fan of him after the
comments many of the cast members of
harry potter began their journey at such
young ages they had the whole world
watching their every move as they made
mistakes it makes sense they had their
fair share of personal troubles while
dealing with the pressure of worldwide
success
which scandal surprised you most